all right marty nice to see you again
how's things been for you it's been a
month or two since i've seen you last
i've been doing a lot of uh
struggling out there
what's been the hardest part of your
life lately
any money for something to eat lost a
lot of weight
yeah you haven't showered in a while too
it looks like he hasn't shot yeah we
cleaned up in a while
that that that that hurts too
it takes his toe yeah it just makes it
hard for you to feel good about anything
nice
hungry and dirty
do you view the world as a is a cruel
place or
how do you see people you see people as
generally good or
i see people generally as good but
at times i could see it the the the the
total
the the uh the total uh other way around
yeah there's some of both it's always a
balance right
have you spoken to your son at all or
anything like that
it's been a while since since i i i
i spoke to my son yeah
what is your daily routine typically you
wake up where are you living now
you're just you have a blanket you just
curl up on the sidewalk somewhere
and you so when you wake up in the
morning what do you what do you do
typically
i try to figure out what
what what what what what where do i have
to go to
to to get some money today yeah
so you're are you panhandling are you
yeah sometimes too
yeah how much money will you get in a
day of
i made i made about three dollars one
time panhandling
over over over over by the the park
the bar station with the uh
the cable cars come down
what was the best time of your life
when when my son was born
your life was happy though yes it was
how did things begin to change for you
what what what happened that you ended
up
now living on the street
you're using uh crystal meth right yeah
i love i love getting high
the crystal meth really relieves all the
d d d
d d
d d
d depression that i get
you're depressed one yes i do
what do you think about your past is is
the most problematic for
something you your childhood yeah my
childhood
you won't be the child that that i had
you won't believe it if i told you
no one's ever been treated as fast as me
was the worst part
just being knee knee
knee knee
knee knee
knee neglected
not feeling wanted at all
do you ever did do you feel like you
were ever loved in your life
well there's a song that says the
greatest love of all it's just
it's just it's to love love of yourself
so i've tried to love myself
since since i've been out here waiting
to get picked up
that hasn't
picked up the city
is this the worst part of your life
right now you think what you're going
through
no
what do you think would help you the
most
housing therapy rehab
getting picked up by my family
do they know you're out here yes
marty would you like to wash up and take
a shower yes
do you ever feel like life is just
unfair
i do
with the childhood you had it would be
easy to think that right
yes
what was it what was the roughest thing
you went through in your childhood
you said neglect but i mean
what kind of stuff would your parents do
to you
my mom would would wait for me every day
when i come home from school like this
she she would make me flinch as as i
walked by her she's making me excuse
either
punched me or hit me and back in my head
or she would do nothing
she wouldn't do anything to me at all
that was the worst thing coming home
from school
you still have hope for a better life
how old do you know
i'm 53 53 do you still have hope for
getting your life together and having a
better life yes
what would you say to your family if you
saw them after all these years
i don't know
it's good it's a good uh question
marty do you feel like you were treated
unfairly in life
all i know is i wrote a pair of sixes
but i didn't pass go
i deserve to get picked up
all right marty well thank you for
coming in again thank you for talking
with me
i'm gonna help you out today thank you
thank you
you